we do have a journey for you with us
Jennifer an amazing Victory
congratulations you must be buzzing with
excitement for tomorrow's playoff
yeah I
got her match tomorrow I was just I
don't know after yesterday I just
thought it was over
I just thought I was done like I was
like this is just awful
um but I'm really happy I have another
chance to go for the title again because
I mean after a way I played yesterday I
was like I just honestly don't deserve
another chance what did you do yesterday
after uh that loss to come back
um
I don't know I usually uh like recover
after losses pretty quickly like I just
get over it really fast but you know
when you lose like that like I played a
move that I don't think I would have
played like when I was like eight years
old I don't know I was like literally
hallucinating I did not know what I was
doing and then after I played it I was
like damn like I thought because I
thought I lost like the title with that
move I was like because otherwise I was
like oh I'm doing fine here
um and I knew that and I was just like I
I don't know what was going on so
um after that I was just like you know I
honestly don't deserve a chance like the
way I've been playing was just awful but
you see still still came back with the
black pieces against the surging player
five wins in a row for Talia very
difficult opponent how did you approach
this one
a charger no so basically I pretended
this game like I had no chances off I
was like I don't really care like I'm
just gonna play like normal
um I didn't look at irena's game the
entire round I only saw it like after I
finished
um I was just like just pretend like
it's over
um and just play normally because
otherwise there's just too much to think
about because usually I do find Under
Pressure it's just like after yesterday
like it's actually because I keep
thinking back on I'm like why would you
play that move like it's just so bad
um so that's kind of my mentality I just
kind of do like some mental gymnastics
there I feel like Reno was doing
something very similar because I didn't
see her looking at your game either she
was very focused on her game as well you
were very focused on your game as well
and you guys were very close to each
other you didn't pick at all no I like I
try like I I think I was looking at like
the screen that had like all the games
on it I like accidentally picked her
game once I was like no that's too much
I was like no I have to I can't look at
that game because it's not even like the
pressure it just makes me feel so mad at
myself for the way I played yesterday
because I just felt like I threw it away
completely when did you feel like you
were actually getting realistic chances
in this one
um so from the opening I
um I definitely surprised her here
because like I've never played this
before and definitely was not that good
but here at Queen before I just started
feeling pretty good about my station
because
um like this end game is just very
comfortable for me to play I can just I
feel like I basically can't really lose
it if I just like keep um the pressure
don't let her play like F3 or F4 at some
point
um because what happened in the game was
like she just got very passive and then
um yeah like she didn't really have any
moves at some point and he found this
nice idea against this Knight C3 Knight
day four with which Basics to put
pressure on E2 first and then defend
with route to p8 yeah very nice and at
this point I think it was this moment
sometime after you play this move d4 did
you see these move Rooks to C3 yeah I
thought Rook C3 I looked at Rook C3 more
after Ed CD Rook T3 but that that's just
D3 um I thought I assumed after coming
here here right now this just doesn't
work yeah
um I assume that
I could play D3 here too but I think
oh right
that's tricky
yeah it was a tricky move and I think
you have to do something like Rook F7 or
look at Faith but it becomes a bit
trickier than yeah maybe it should have
been no I like
um near the end of time Metro I think I
misplayed it a bit because like this is
fine but it's I think there's easier
ways to win and
um I think in a few more moves so after
Rook A4
[Music]
um
yeah right here that you found uh yeah
so I like At first I wanted to play
um so I saw this a few moves in advance
and I thought I was just gonna play uh
E3 and then I was like oh this Brook
takes C3 because this is just like
really different wow no you threw like I
saw this like moves ago in advance I was
like E3 just doesn't work when I got
like a customer T3 into draw yes and I
was like that's bad and then I was
thinking um Rook takes G3 Rook F and
then E3 but then Rook D and then you're
like oh the pawns are pushy but then
rook d393 and perfectly Keen F3 and I
think this isn't as easy as it looks
because it's so tricky with uh you have
to be so careful not to lose age up this
guy and not lose the H5 Pawn Yeah
because that's the problem I think I
could pick up the G and H pawns pretty
easily but do you have this move on is
probably not Rook A1 yeah
um and then so I was just like you know
I spent a lot of time and I was like
Knight G6 seems pretty simple to play
yep um yeah and that was actually
winning and after that you went on uh to
convert
Jennifer congratulations big one how are
you going to prepare for tomorrow's
playoff
it's her again but you know to start
like forget kind of about the tournament
like Bishop A4 and then just kind of
start clean
um I haven't the last time I played the
playoff was actually at us Junior so I
have a little bit experience but I
didn't really have time to prepare for
that one because it was the same day so
um I hopefully I can do more this time
and you know I'm just really excited to
have another opportunity because I mean
it's just a really interesting
tournament now I guess you know it's
more exciting why don't you go get your
rest and we'll see you tomorrow
our congratulations Jennifer good luck
in tomorrow's playoff we're going to be
here to call all the actions yeah I mean
and here it is uh once again ladies a
championship